all right question for eric from
hayato nishiyama i hear people talk
about
bcaas all the time um but i really don't
hear people talk about
eaas or essential amino acids
essential amino acids are more expensive
than bcaas but
are they actually better or is it a
waste of money like
bcaas are so this is a good question
definitely bcaas have had their place uh
kind of up in the royal family of
supplements in the bodybuilding world
um or at least they had i feel like
they've kind of lost that foothold
but um i don't know why i'm not certain
why
the branch chain amino acids rose to
prominence and the essential amino acids
didn't i think for a while there um
greg am i crazy for thinking that for a
while there
there just weren't any decent tasting
eaa formulas out there
i feel like there were potentially
flavoring issues that led people to go
down the
the bcaa route i mean possibly
uh i think a lot of that would probably
depend on leucine dosing because leucine
tastes
terrible yeah yeah so
i don't know why the companies decided
hey let's go all in on
on branch chains but definitely if you
looked at the market
just based on the products that were
available there is a lot more emphasis
on branch chains than than essential
amino acids
and just to kind of set the framework
here so
the branched chain amino acids are three
amino acids that do happen to be
essential amino acids but an essential
amino acid
product just has the other essential
amino acids as well
so the branch change our branch chains
are basically
a subcategory of the essential amino
acids
and then there are also non-essential
amino acids in the diet
now the reason the essential amino acids
are important is because if you intend
to do something crazy like
build some muscle proteins then you're
going to need all the essential amino
acids present in sufficient quantities
um now as the
asker of the question alluded to the the
the more popular opinion these days is
that
branch chain amino acid products
probably have a lot more limited utility
than we used to think or than we than
used to be kind of
commonly thought so back in the day i
mean you were not going to find a
bodybuilder that wasn't carrying around
a gallon jug
full of unusually purple water
and without question the reason it was
purple was because there are branched
chain amino acids in it
and they would basically just sip on it
all day like a leucine drip
and i think a lot of people were really
into this idea
and by the way leucine is one of the
branch chain amino acids
but i think a lot of people were really
into this idea that if you just kind of
consistently sipped on branch chains
it's like okay we're gonna stay slightly
anabolic like
pretty much around the clock and with
what we've
learned about the temporal
aspects of muscle protein synthesis and
muscle protein breakdown
that doesn't seem to be a good strategy
so
the people that were putting a lot of
eggs in that basket i mean their water
tasted better
than it otherwise would have in most
cases but aside from that it probably
wasn't doing
a ton for them and to be honest i just
can't think of a
super great use for branched chain amino
acids
um i i can think of maybe some uses for
essential amino acids but
really what we're getting at here with
using an essential amino acid supplement
maybe you could argue that if someone
was on
a let's say like a vegan diet on fairly
limited calories
so they couldn't one of the tricky
things about vegan diets
is you have to make sure that you're
getting
uh enough protein intake that
you know by putting all these different
protein sources together
you're getting the essential amino acids
you need throughout the day
and one of the challenges with that is
finding
vegan proteins that have diverse amino
acid profiles
that don't also have a decent amount of
fat or carbohydrate in them
and so it can get pretty tough without
supplementation
to put together a low calorie high
protein vegan diet
it can get really challenging without
question
now if you choose to consume a vegan
diet i got
zero problems with that totally fine
with that um
but there are some challenges there when
it comes to meeting those
those needs for amino acid intakes
so i could maybe see the utility of an
essential amino acid
product in that context um
maybe like i know one way that people
like to use this
is for an intra-workout kind of deal
where they're like oh i want to have
intra-workout protein but
in order to make digestion a little
easier
maybe and maybe you know uptake
quicker absorption maybe i'll go with
essential amino acids
i guess if you're comparing it kind of
apples to apples there
the essential amino acids probably would
make more sense but
i think there's a very limited number of
people who really need to be having
intra-workout
protein supplementation so even with
that
justification i don't think it's a
particularly
i don't think you're likely to see a
very big benefit from that personally
um maybe if you are about to do a pretty
intense workout
and you're like you know what i don't
want to go in there completely faster
i'd like to have some amino acids some
kind of
some kind of amino acids in the
bloodstream during and then immediately
after the workout
um if maybe if you wanted to do that but
you couldn't eat
a full protein a full impre intact food
based protein because
it just your stomach cannot handle
digesting those proteins during the
workout
maybe there might be an application
there but the one thing i want to
highlight is
as you can imagine these uh scenarios
that i'm constructing for trying to find
a really good val
really good uh justified use for them
you have to start putting kind of like a
few circumstantial factors together
to make these scenarios i i personally
think that the the
supplementation
i think the promise of branch chain and
essential amino acid supplementation
is very limited to very specific
specific circumstances
at best i i can i can throw one out
there that
um i do think applies to probably a
non-negligible amount of people
sure what do you got so i think that um
i think that there's been a lot of
backlash against bcaas
probably to a degree that's not
completely warranted
uh because the thing is i think a lot of
the backlash is they were
so hyped a few years ago and now there's
more and more research is coming in
and we realize like the the level of
hype we saw probably wasn't justified
but the thing is there is a lot of
research on branch
chains and into a lesser degree
essential amino acids which
probably are just as good as branched
chains if not slightly better
but there there is a fair amount of work
on branched chain amino acids
looking at recovery from resistance
training
to the point that there's a few
meta-analyses at this point
and those metas do find that
compared to a placebo which is almost
always maltodextrin
um branched-chain amino acids do improve
recovery from
from exercise training and so the
problem
is that even though there's i don't know
probably 15 or 20 studies at this point
comparing branch chains to
a placebo they've never been compared to
just like straight up whey protein
to see the effects on recovery from
resistance exercise
and in all likelihood like i mean we
know
protein does the same stuff you give
people protein versus a placebo protein
also improves recovery from resistance
exercise
and so in all likelihood branch chain
amino acids
don't do any better than protein and and
very well could be worse than protein
for recovery from resistance exercise
so that's like a glaring hole in the
literature
but one thing to note just from a
practical perspective is that
a lot of people um and myself included
here
so i don't use branch chain amino acids
but i kind of think i probably
should because i don't want to eat
directly after a workout
i kind of get around that because i'm
one of the weird people who can eat a
lot right before a workout and i'm
totally fine
but especially with using protein
supplements
if i use particularly whey protein
within an hour
of finishing a training session it
always makes me feel nauseated
and you know if i'm hot and like a
little overheated from a training
session i don't want to
immediately go home and eat a huge meal
like i probably
don't really want to eat again until
maybe two
two-ish hours after a training session
and so
in my case if i would be comparing
branched chain amino acids against
nothing branched chain amino acids very
well
might help me i don't use them because
i'm cheap as [ __ ]
but but
i i do know and this is feedback i've
heard from a lot of people when
i have [ __ ] on branch chain amino acids
in the past
um where they're like i just can't
consume protein around workouts like it
always makes me feel really nauseated i
don't have much of an appetite
but i can sip on branched chain amino
acids and that's totally fine
and so like i don't think that that
applies to a large majority of people
but if you do compare branch chains
against
nothing it is it is better than nothing
like
that is something you can confidently
say about it so if you're someone who
just
just doesn't want to consume protein
around a training session because it
like
upsets your stomach makes you feel
nauseated you probably will get some
utility from
branch chain amino acid supplementation
yeah so i did mention that scenario in
the pre-exercise
um context but i didn't think about the
post because that's never been a problem
for me
i'm the opposite i struggled to train on
a full stomach but right after i can eat
usually yeah but um that would make
sense um in that scenario i would
speculate that an essential amino acid
product
if i'm i would speculate would probably
be even
a better option no i i agree than branch
chain amino acids
um so so to answer the question um i
would say
most the places where you can really
justify using either branch chains or
essential amino acids
i do think that you would at least be
inclined to
um slightly have a
more favorable view of the essential
amino acids because
uh i i just think there's inherent
benefit to having a more complete amino
acid profile than just the branch chains
in that supplement so you know
the the two most likely scenario is
playing the numbers
as we mentioned you don't have the
stomach for having
whole intact proteins that require
greater digestion
you know before after a workout or you
uh
are consuming a diet that is most mostly
plentiful in
lower quality proteins so i'm thinking
usually a vegan diet and you are simply
using it to supplement the amino acid
profile of some of those lower quality
proteins
i do want to bring i want to like limp
into the this the discussion here with a
couple like
takes that i'm not fully committed to
[Laughter]
so um a couple recent things that are
just
my bias generally speaking is to lean
toward
food when food can work and then when it
can't work
then embrace supplementation so i'm not
anti-supplement by any means but
you know for for me i'm i'm always
thinking what is it going to take to
shift me away from a food and toward a
supplement
or if a supplement just cannot be
obtained from food then that decision
is easy but with amino acids i'm always
thinking why am i not going to have a
delicious hamburger
and instead i'm going to have some kind
of weird
amino acid mixture replacing food
and so or a weird and sad simulacrum of
lasagna
potentially that's we'll talk about that
later
um so there was a review paper
by a few authors that i would just
mispronounce
all of their names uh yong kwing ho
yulong yin and wu
but this paper came out in 2015. if you
want to search it
maybe we'll go with the title not the
author names that i just there's no way
you could
possibly figure out how to spell those
um dietary essentiality of nutritionally
non-essential amino acids for animals
and humans
and basically what they were
highlighting in the paper is that
non-essential amino acids
do play important roles in things like
gene expression cell signaling
digestion absorption dna and protein
synthesis
proteolysis metabolism endocrine status
a whole bunch of things
uh that that several non-essential amino
acids play very critical roles in
and what what the general argument they
were making is
is that the extreme focus and emphasis
on essential amino acids in the diet has
maybe
undersold the role that dietary
non-essential amino acids play so so
they're basically saying hey by calling
them non-essential
we've really um we've really downplayed
exactly
exactly how important it is to get some
of these amino acids from the diet
there was also a very interesting paper
in 2019
uh this one was called branched chain
amino acids impact health and lifespan
indirectly via amino acid imbalance
or i guess it's amino acid balance and
appetite control
but when you read the paper they're
really focused on imbalance
but what they were doing it was a rodent
study and and they basically looked at
these
rats or mice and they tweaked the the
branch chain amino acid content
of their diets and because there's long
been this kind of weird observation that
uh high branch chain amino acid intake
seems to be associated
with like diabetes and and uh insulin
resistance
and so the question is what's what
exactly is going on there
because it's just an association not
necessarily a causal relationship
um so a lot of times people see those
associations and they say like oh
branch chains are gonna give me diabetes
um but what
what they found with their study again
it's one study it's a rodent model we
don't know
exactly how well it's gonna translate
over to humans i'm by no means an amino
acid metabolism expert
but what they found was that when they
really ramped up the branch chain amino
acid content of the diets
what they found was they basically
induced an imbalance between the branch
chain amino acids
and essentially all the other dietary
amino acids that would be taken in
and the ones that they really focused in
on were tryptophan and three
threonine uh and what they found was
that this was associated with
hyperphagia which is
an increased appetite and central
serotonin depletion
what they were getting at is that by
drastically increasing the branch chain
amino acid content of the diet
maybe by inducing this imbalance that
would not typically be found in
the normal protein sources of the diet
for these animals maybe that imbalance
was
triggering hyperphagia and some other
unwanted uh
kind of unintended consequences of
altering that balance
that caused them to essentially overeat
i don't
again i'm completely limping in with
very not strong takes on this but
there are at least some kind of
rumblings in the literature that would
make you think
kind of they basically support my bias
that i came to the conversation with
with
which is basically you have to convince
me to move
away from food toward amino acid
supplementation or at least
give me good reason to believe that
these are truly equivalent things that
are worth swapping
so aside from the very special because
the reason i bring this up is everyone's
always like
yeah but what if i had this awesome
extremely supercharged diet that has
like
all these very complex like i'm
supplementing
you know all these different amino acids
at all these different times
because this is better than just a
standard diet with plenty of protein in
it
i have some reservations about getting
super complicated about
all these different dosing protocols for
different amino acid mixtures
i think for me right now unless you're
in some of those really
specialized scenarios that we talked
about where we're like okay it makes a
lot of sense to put in like branch
chains or essential amino acids
barring those circumstances we already
kind of put forward i think
generally speaking if you're having a
a diet with sufficient protein that's
got plenty of high quality protein
sources in it
most of your amino acid needs are going
to be met
and really not worth getting too
concerned about